on
nous sommes là aujourd'hui pour lancer
un message fort approprié à macky sall
connu dire que nous n'accepterons pas
aujourd'hui que soit son but soit
sacrifié comme l'a fait avec les autres
opposants l'onu farhan haq a donné aux
femmes ne sont que mon fils n'est qu'à
kanaker les profits du second tour
m
le club
ce qu'il appelle
regrettable je ne sais pas ce qu'il en
est dans le fond je ne peux pas
souhaiter à mon pire adversaire
une telle situation maintenant il ya une
accusation
il ya des procédures vraiment il faut
pas qu'on met le plus de choses qui ne
s'éclaire quoique j'ai suffisamment de
choses à faire que de comploter pour là
dessus aussi basse
on ne rit pas remis